[Music]
tonight I'm Brian Ross investigates the
deadliest terror attacks since 9/11 with
Isis claiming responsibility tonight a
focus on the secret weapon Isis fighters
left behind their children pollinators
in genetics then to say Gina and its
careful well hiya did plus the u.s.
prices for continued Russian efforts to
interfere in the 2020 presidential
elections even as the president's
son-in-law claims it was really no big
deal I think the investigations and and
all the the speculation has happened for
the last two years has had a much
harsher impact on democracy that a
couple of Facebook as we're joined by
the chair of the Federal Election
Commission
Ellen windrow plus are shut up for the
reporters who exposed shocking
conditions inside Philadelphia schools
flaking lead paint falling on student
desks and he was scared that he'd get in
trouble having a messy desk and he ate
the lead paint chips on his desk from
the law and crime Network studios in New
York City this is Brian Ross
investigates good evening and welcome
tonight the threat from Isis the Easter
Sunday attacks in Sri Lanka amounted to
the deadliest terror attacks since 9/11
here in New York raising concerns among
US officials that the group that had
been pronounced as dead and buried was
anything but
this morning eight explosions rocking
churches and luxury hotels in Sri Lanka
eight coordinated bombings across the
country that they have not allowed
anyone to go inside to check the damage
so there are reported laughs at what is
inside more than 300 dead churchgoers
children the innocent a senseless act
that left people in Sri Lanka and around
the world in grief and despair and what
worries US officials are the claims of
responsibility by the terror group Isis
which used its social media outlets to
post these videos of the supposed
suicide bombers swearing allegiance to
Isis before the attacks just weeks after
President Trump declared the battle
against Isis a huge success
the Isis Caliphate has been decimated
nobody thought it was possible to do it
this quickly but now a new documentary
Isis tomorrow the lost souls of those
being seen here for the first time shows
how the children of Isis may well be a
new generation of fighters carrying out
the same goals as their fathers
to an internet ad watch what I do I show
not just the amount of work
you know very much hooyah much only per
century
literally I don't wanna be a garbage
disposal mom in centerfield McLouth and
not the offical at ne a-- -
yeah namenda Robbins a bizarre-o tatar
america neo-kowloon obama's Abu Hassan
al-bakr unicoos nobuseri Carmarthen had
a lot of Eliquis Oh
[Music]
I'm most upset
our Father mired in my own energy why
are you okay - announcer - Marvin tapes
one it would not either either in Hoonah
Desmond who not far we don't have a
system Attica
[Music]
joining us now is the director of that
amazing film franceska manake and karen
greenberg who's the director of the
center on national security at Fordham
University School of Law thank you both
for joining us franceska what an amazing
film to be in there with all those
children in those camps how long did it
take you to do that and were they so
forthcoming to you thanks Brian thanks
for having me here it took one year and
a half one and a half we we start the
beginning of the offensive in 2016 we
started filming this documentary in
October we are in October 2016 till last
May May 2018 ten trips in in in Iraq
mountain rocks planning meeting these
people meeting the families of Isis part
of the relative of Isis fighter as his
family's Isis Widow as his orphan as his
children people already stigmatize
already abandoned both during the
offensive both during the war and now
much more than before they are living in
these camps they are living without any
kind of aid without electricity without
the right of aides or food aid or the
right to return to school and I think we
have the responsibility to humanize
these families in these people
Karen Greenberg is you watch this film
what's your takeaway about the threat
that these young children may one day
pose to the US and the world I think the
threat of instability throughout the
region is going to persist for a long
time and that the instability of these
children who are not sufficiently taken
care of and not sufficiently educated
not sufficiently fed at times is going
to is going to be a problem and I think
that the the fact that it's a problem
can't mean that the countries of the
world run away for it they have to
address as this film tells you very
clearly building a new civil society
throughout the region we have a question
from our control room where they helped
me Rhonda moment Rhonda
our executive producer Rhonda Francesca
it's a great documentary it's no expense
seems to have been spared to go after
Isis what needs to be done for the women
and children in these camps
what did thanks for the question Rhonda
I think that they we as a journalist and
I'm speaking as a journalist we need to
build a counter narrative on these
families we described these families
this father and their families just a
black monolith and this kind of
narrative
let's public opinion and what's the
government to tolerate everything in
name of security so we have to begin to
describe these people like human beings
not like just an enemy a mother is a
mother a children she'd read children a
child is a child no matter who is the
father is suffering it cannot attend
school so we have to take the burden of
the responsibility for this generation
and with that stabilization that goes on
there are Isis children what's the
impact do you think Karen Reber gone the
children themselves it just sort of
prepares them to be fighting back it's
not just about fighting back it's what
we know about early childhood young
children what deprivation does to their
brains what fear what being in war zones
does to the development of their brains
so we're really talking about a crisis
that's in the moment and it's a look
we've watched the world try to balance
security versus civil society now for
almost two decades and we haven't quite
figured it out yet and now we have a
crisis in which we all almost have to
start immediately and just take the best
of our knowledge and not run away from
this problem Francesca are there mental
health professionals helping these
children as they're counseling for them
not enough definitely not enough there
are refugees camp which are in the
middle of nowhere not only in Iraq
described in the documentary but the
case of Macoutes it's hopeful case I
mean they were expected to have 10,000
people and they are facing 8,000 people
and among them there are 11,000
foreigners for more than 30
nationalities and all these countries
are refusing to bring them back so
they're stuck there in the middle of the
Caribbean where do you think they're
going to end up I think I hope that a
number of these countries will actually
take them back that the that the adults
that are accused of supporting Isis one
way or another will will agree to face
some kind of judicial process that the
children will be taken care of that's
the just thing to do particularly when
rendering individual stateless is
considered to violate international law
and just quickly what is the u.s.
position that the u.s. position has been
that they have not yet made up their
minds what they're going to do it is it
is now being litigated through the
courts and it's standing by for them
that goes somewhere it was the question
is will they repatriate in particular
this one woman but she's not the only
one and what will happen with their
children well thank you very much for
being here
francisco jessica manake and karen
greenberg thank you very much an amazing
film and thank you for sharing it first
here with us and the law and crime
Network I hope others get to see it soon
there's some powerful lessons to be
learned there thank you
coming up the Russians are coming
everyone seems to know it but the man in
the White House we will talk with the
chair of the Federal Election Commission
Ellen Weintraub when we come back
the molar report found a sweeping and
systemic effort by the Russians to
interfere in the last presidential
election and there's every indication
that the same team of Russian
intelligence agents and operatives are
prepared to do it again or maybe already
on the case yet the White House seems to
be in complete denial about all of this
according to the New York Times the
Homeland Security Secretary was told not
to raise the issue with President Trump
that he equated discussion of the
Russian interference with questions
about the legitimacy of his victory and
this week the president's son-in-law and
advisor Jared Kushner told an audience
in New York that in his view the Russian
interference was not really a big deal
and quite frankly the whole thing is
just a big distraction for the country
and you look at you know what Russia did
you know binds from Facebook gets to try
to sow dissent and do it and it's a
terrible thing but I think the
investigations and and all the
speculation that's happened for the last
two years has had a much harsher impact
on our democracy that a couple of
facebook ads and I spend about I think
they said they spend about 160,000 I
spend a hundred and sixty thousand
dollars on Facebook every three hours
during the campaign so now if you look
at the magnitude of what they did and
what they accomplished I think the
ensuing investigations have been way
more harmful joining us now from
Washington is the chair of the Federal
Election Commission
Ellen Weintraub commissioner thank you
very much for being here
pleasure to be here Brian let me start
by asking you the president's son-in-law
Jared Kushner seems to think that
Russian meddling was no big deal
you called it a threat to American
democracy and our national security
which is it well the special counsel
said that the Russian government
interfered in our elections in a
sweeping and systemic fashion and I
think that all Americans really ought to
be very concerned about this this comes
on top of the assessments of the
National Security Administration the
intelligence community the Director of
National Intelligence all of them have
been giving us the same message
over and over again that the Russians
interfered they interfered in a
significant way and we need to take
steps to make sure it doesn't happen
again
is it your expectation they'll do the
same thing in 2020
I think they'll certainly try and
perhaps not only the Russians and by
that way you mean what well I think that
other countries may also try and
intervene and do you think the systems
here are so weak that it's easy pickins
well let me say that our jurisdiction
does not extend to the homeland security
piece of this there are all sorts of
state and local election officials who
are working with the Department of
Homeland Security to try and shore up
their protections against hacking and
interfering and attempts to change the
vote so there is a lot of activity going
on at the national state and local level
to put us in a much better position than
we were in 2016 I think that some people
were taken by surprise in 2016 and we
certainly will not be taken by surprise
again so you see the Miller report is
sort of a call to arms call to action
absolutely what can you do at the
Commission because in the past it's also
been seen as a toothless tiger well that
is unfortunate but I am hoping that on
this issue we might be able to get some
consensus you know we recently had
released an enforcement action where we
find a super PAC and domestic subsidiary
of a foreign company almost a million
dollars for a foreign contribution that
was routed through the domestic
subsidiary now that was one of the
larger penalties that this agency has
agreed on in years and we were able to
agree on that I think because of the
importance of this issue so I am hoping
that going forward we can achieve more
consensus on measures to address foreign
spending in
elections and are there any civil
actions you could take about what
happened in 2016 even though they were
prosecuted criminally by Muller around
the US Attorney in the Southern District
of New York
are there action you can take
specifically for instance the payments
to hush up the women who allegedly had
affairs of Donald Trump I can't speak to
any enforcement actions that the agency
may have pending before it or could have
pending before it in the future so I
can't speak to any specifics however we
do have civil enforcement authority it
is not the same as the criminal justice
system we don't we can't throw anybody
in jail on the other hand we don't have
to approve things beyond a reasonable
doubt it's a lower standard of proof so
there are actions that we could take
sometimes where the Justice Department
cannot act by your token what do you
make of President Trump essentially
trying to ignore this issue the report
of the New York Times this week that the
Homeland Security Secretary was advised
don't tell him about this Russian
meddling it doesn't go over well well
I'm not going to speak to what's going
on in the White House I think that this
is a critically important issue and most
of the government officials that I know
are taking it very seriously how do you
get into the issue of who's buying ads
on Facebook and social media it's very
hard to track it is hard to track but I
think we are doing a better job of it
and the platforms are doing a better job
of it than they did before one thing
that we really have to do is improve our
disclosure of who is behind the ads and
the disclaimers that are on the ads
there's been a pending rulemaking for
far too long here at the Commission and
I am trying my artists to move that
forward so how would that work well we
would get better information and it
would be clear that it is required on
every single ad on the platforms on
digital platforms as well as are
currently required for broadcast ads for
example that the spender behind the ads
would have to be identified on the face
of the ad and if not who would be
responsible that'd be Facebook or
Twitter well whoever placed the ad would
be
responsible generally but the platform's
have been I think trying to be more
responsible about this and trying to
adapt their ad platforms to include more
information but do you think for
instance Facebook or other social media
outlets should be held responsible as
well
do they have an obligation here I think
that they do have an obligation like
everyone in America who has any part of
this activity to do everything in their
power to ensure that the American public
is well-informed and that foreigners are
not intervening in our election and are
not spending money in our elections
Thank You Commissioner Ellen Weintraub
of the Federal Election Commission
coming up our shout out to the team of
reporters in Philadelphia who exposed
shocking conditions in city schools that
officials seem to have ignored
you
our shout out tonight for a remarkable
piece of investigative journalism that
has already had huge impact on the lives
and health of schoolchildren in
Philadelphia it was news that shocked
the city dangerous levels of mold lead
asbestos inside more than a dozen
Philadelphia schools all the result of a
two-year long project called toxic city
SiC schools by the Philadelphia Inquirer
and two enterprising reporters I'm Wendy
Ruderman I'm a reporter for the
Philadelphia Inquirer and I'm Barbara
Laker I'm a reporter also for the
Philadelphia Enquirer after the scandal
of dangerous lead levels in the drinking
water in Flint Michigan the two
reporters wanted to know what the story
was in Philadelphia we wanted to take a
look at Philadelphia's numbers and see
if children in Philadelphia were being
exposed to lead and we learned that kids
in Philadelphia were actually exposed to
lead and had lead poisoning at far
higher rates than in Flint Michigan and
so they looked first at homes and
landlords then playgrounds and finally
school we were actually really shocked
how bad that conditions were in the
schools but it took months of work to
prove it and a lot of stealth finding
teachers to conduct tests inside the
school teachers were very reluctant they
were afraid of retribution from the
school district but ultimately we did
get 26 teacher to help us do the testing
and 19 of the most rundown schools the
reporters could not go into schools
themselves to avoid being accused of
trespassing and it was all very
hush-hush
as the equipment and test results were
passed back and forth it was almost like
it was like a drug deal or something
that was kind of funny and crazy but
they would hand us these little vials
filled with dose wipes and then we would
take them over to the lab the results
made headlines Asian teachers at a
Philadelphia K through 8 school have
just about had and students at one of
the schools even wrote letters to local
officials we need funding for
very school it's like the school is
falling apart
dear state senator Vincent use every day
I go to school I feel like I'm in a
prison or a junkyard
the school can probably break down any
time so our doors are broken broken
computers and leaking heaters we had one
little boy Dean Pugin he was a first
grader in a school and he was sitting at
his desk trying to learn and there was a
ton of lead paint on the ceiling above
his desk and it fell on his desk and on
the floor beside his desk and he was
scared that he'd get in trouble having a
messy desk and he thought he'd also the
teacher would be mad at him if he got up
to put it in the trashcan so we ate the
lead paint chips on his desk and he
ended up having a lead level of like 46
which is I mean off-the-charts high he
was hospitalized for three days and
nights and he was left the reporters say
with serious learning disabilities this
afternoon the mayor and other city
leaders visited a middle school the
story finally got the attention of
school officials who at first had been
highly critical of the reporter's
efforts the testing methodology that was
employed by the reporters we have
already come out and been very clear
that we don't agree with that but under
public pressure the schools launched a
massive 15 million dollar cleanup
campaign at the seven schools named by
the Philadelphia Inquirer as having the
worst conditions but that sort of raises
questions about on all the schools that
we didn't get into and we couldn't get
teachers to test or we just you know
it's just it's just so vast it was a big
commitment from our newsroom and it
involved pretty much the whole staff and
yes myself and Barbara and Dylan Purcell
who helped us do a lot of the data
analysis of maintenance Long's
ultimately our job is to expose
something that's wrong and shed light on
it and then empower people with
knowledge
then on top of that empower the
community to actually pick up the ball
and have conversations that make change
and that's what's happening here in
Philly so our shout out to Wendy
Ruderman and Barbara Laker and their
investigations editor Jim Neff and the
Philadelphia Inquirer for clearing the
path for this huge undertaking
investigative reporting at its very best
that's our program for tonight thanks
for joining us
we'll see you again here next week good
night